remous monétaire jacques delors
s'explique
valéry giscard d'estaing première
interview le bol d'or motocycliste la
passion du risque
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir une
forte chute du dollar
une ruée sur le mark allemand et lefranc
attaqué la fin de semaine a été rude sur
les marchés financiers hier la banque de
france a dû vendre massivement des
dollars
on parle d'un milliard de francs et dans
l'après-midi la psychose de la
dévaluation du franc a réapparu pour
être plus précis les financiers évoqués
un réajustement de la parité des
monnaies au sein du système monétaire
européen
cet après midi le ministère de
l'économie a voulu couper court à ces
rumeurs
le ministère a annoncé deux mesures elle
concerne le contrôle des changes et le
relèvement des taux d'intérêt pour le
gouvernement la stabilité de la monnaie
est considérée comme un élément
essentiel de sa politique économique
deux mesures donc annoncé par la rue de
rivoli la banque de france va d'abord
modifier son dispositif d'intervention
afin d'obtenir un relèvement des taux du
marché monétaire
deuxièmement la faculté pour les
importateurs d'acheter des devises à
terme est temporairement suspendue pour
le ministère de l'économie
c'est un effort de solidarité qui était
assis demandé aux entreprises dans le
cadre général du développement de notre
économie
deux mesures philippe sassier qui
demande quelques éclaircissements et
justement vallée demandé à jacques
delors et faisait pas mal de questions
pour s'y reconnaître un petit peu dans
ce jargon assez peu romantique des
crises bta qui se succèdent depuis
bientôt dix ans alors nous allons donc
d'abord parler du franc et puis ensuite
quand même parce que le front est très
liée à la politique économique à la vie
quotidienne et des citoyens et les
entreprises de landon parler ensuite la
politique économique première donc
question monsieur le ministre vous
refusé une nouvelle fois de dévaluer
alors pourquoi tenir tellement à ce
fameux système monétaire européen m ce
s'assied nous sommes en plein désordre
monétaire mondial
celui que je dénonce sans trêve depuis
quatre mois dont j'estime qui est un
facteur extraordinaire de
déstabilisation des économies et d'apopo
d'appauvrissement des pays les plus
pauvres
par conséquent d'autant de temps en
temps c'est le dollar qui monte à
d'autres moments il baisse brutalement
dans un cas comme dans l'autre il n'ya
pas de stabilisation possible et tous
les indices que l'on peut voir aux états
unis ne nous permettent pas d'y voir
clair
par conséquent il n'y a qu'une seule
possibilité
c'est dans cette oasis relative que le
système monétaire européen se défendre
afin d'éviter à notre économie
les chocs de ces turbulences monétaires
de leur pensée tout de même pas que les
bruits ces derniers jours de
nationalisation par exemple des banques
étrangères installées en france a pu
nourrir aussi cette variation sur les
marchés monétaires et il faut distinguer
me semble-t-il
ces derniers jours où effectivement
ensemble comme une corde et toutes les
monnaies du sml ont dû se défendre
il n'y a pas que la france qui la veille
à la belgique l'irlande l'allemagne et
cetera mais j'ai entendu dire
effectivement que jeudi et vendredi des
étrangers qui avaient des capitaux en
france auraient été effrayés par cette
rumeur selon laquelle les banques
étrangères pourraient être nationalisées
je répétais ici avec force qu'il n'en
est pas question vous dites rumeurs ce
conseil d'état qu'il demande
non le conseil d'état dit vous pourriez
peut-être le conseil d'état donne un
avis mais enfin le gouvernement était
très net là dessus nous voulons élargir
notre secteur public en restant membre à
part entière de la communauté économique
internationale en respectant nos
engagements internationaux et quand vous
verrez le texte d'ailleurs vous y
constaterez qu'il y a des articles qui
permettent au gouvernement de négocier
avec ceux qui ont des participations
étrangères dans nos entreprises ou dans
nos banques nationalisées et avec ceux
qui sont nos partenaires dans les
participations françaises à l'étranger
par conséquent vis-à-vis de l'étranger
c'est la négociation dans le respect de
nos engagements internationaux qu'elle
se dire que le gouvernement va prendre
des mesures pour s'éviter d'avoir à
nationaliser les banques étrangères
bien sûr bon alors on revient une roue
front pourquoi se cramponnait tellement
un franc que certains estiment surévalué
par rapport aux marques alors qu'une
petite d'évaluation une petite glissade
donnerait permettrait de vendre mieux
plus facilement du made in france
je voulais dit nous on ne peut envisager
des changements monétaire que dans un
climat de stabilité retrouvée à supposer
qu'il soit encore nécessaires à ce
moment là c'est à dire lorsque les
clignotants se sont stabilisés nous n'en
sommes pas là le thermomètre fait ça
tous les jours
comment voulez vous dans ces conditions
faire autre chose que de nous défendre
nous sommes je suis satisfait que le
dollar baisse
car c'est bon pour nous achats de
pétrole et de matières premières mais
qui me dit qu'il est à son véritable tôt
aujourd'hui
et puis il ya plus important que ça
voyez vous le système monétaire européen
comme je vous l'indiquais au détour
d'une phrase c'est une corde et depuis
deux ans et demi qu'il existe il a
permis quand même aux monnaies
européennes d'être un facteur de
stabilité relative au profit de leurs
économies ça n'a pas souffert ça n'a pas
suffi parce que la tempe
mais c'est quand même un élément c'est
un peu comme une mêlée en rugby on est
tous ensemble pour résister à la croire
quand le dollar monte trop on n'est pas
très contents parce que dirait viron
paie trop cher nous matières premières
pétrole mais quand ils descendent le
front est attaqué on n'y comprend plus
rien c'est à dire c'est un peu comme si
nous étions à l'une un parc un moment
nous sommes en haut et puis tout d'un
coup ça bascule de l'autre côté parce
qu'il ya est un gaillard de 100 kg qui
s'y est mis le gaillard 100 kg en
l'espèce ce sont ces capitaux
véritablement flottant qui se dépassent
déplacent en masse des états unis en
allemagne ou d'allemagne aux états unis
parfois en suisse à londres ou ailleurs
et il nous est arrivé ces dernières
semaines d'acheter des devises d'autres
d'en vendre mais ce qui est important et
ce qui est inquiétant c'est la force de
ses mouvements et leur caractère
imprévisible
tant que nous sommes dans ce brouillard
il est impensable de faire autre chose
que de se défendre pour concrètement que
représentent les mesures que vous venez
de prendre et est ce que notamment la
hausse des taux d'intérêt ne risque pas
de le briser une petite reprise et de
gêner les français lorsqu'ils veulent
acheter à crédit
nous demanderons aux banques françaises
de maintenir le taux de base bancaire à
14h30 pour ça l'effort qu'elles ont
consentis en liaison avec notre
politique monétaire nous l'avions permis
par une descente des taux du marché
monétaire
une horloge mandron à titre exceptionnel
de maintenir ce taux de 14 et demi par
conséquent l'augmentation du taux du
marché monétaire qui pourrait résulter
des actions des autorités monétaires
n'aura pour effet que de d'empêcher des
capitaux de quitter la france
mais ça n'aura pas d'incidence sur les
entreprises en cette rentrée un petit
peu turbulente a l'air dans laquelle
nous sommes
capitaux par le fils parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de capitaux qui ont quitté la
france
un jour n'ont pas beaucoup vous demander
un effort aux banques qui est fou c'est
ça vient ça revient sa part ça revient
vous demandez donc un effort aux
banquiers c'est ça afin que cette que le
climat économique ne se détériore pas
trop c'est encore des questions sur les
monnaies ou non sur la mauvaise
lorsqu'on veut passer la politique
économique avant deuxième chef vie mais
qui sont extrêmement liés la violer
ticket économique oui actuellement elles
sont essaye de faire un petit peu un
point comme liz est marin on voit le
chômage qui continue à augmenter en
revanche le commerce extérieur s'est un
petit peu améliorée en août le front est
secoué mais le climat social est serein
bref comment est ce que vous vous voyez
ce c'est rentré quels sont les points
faibles et les points forts
d'abord je dois dire qu'en ce moment
vous ne manquez pas de nouvelles
engadget annonces de réformes et caetera
et dans tout ça le plus important passe
inaperçu le plus important c'est quand
même au deuxième trimestre de l'année la
balance des paiements de la france a été
quasiment équilibré ce qui est quand
même un bon signe pour notre monnaie
pour le marché des changes
le plus important c'est qu'au mois
d'août notre commerce extérieur a été
quasiment équilibré bien entendu une
hirondelle ne fait pas le printemps
lorsque nous reprendrons nos achats de
pétrole
il y aura un certain déficit mais enfin
voilà des facteurs qui sont
encourageants d'autre part les mesures
que nous avons prises en faveur des bas
revenus du salaire minimum des
transferts tout cela a donné une
augmentation du pouvoir d'achat au
deuxième trimestre de l'ordre de 20,7
pour s'en excuser moi je n'abuse pas des
chiffres qui devraient permettre
maintenant de constituer les bases d'une
relance ce ne sont pas en commun et dans
les magasins beaucoup oui ça dépend des
semaines le mois de juillet a été très
bon le mois d'août un peu moins bon au
début de septembre il ya c'est vrai une
hésitation dans les achats mais enfin il
faut pas oublier que d'un autre côté les
épargnants nous ont manifesté une vaste
confiance en souscrivant à l'emprunt que
j'ai émis pour 2 fois le montant que
j'avais prévu par conséquent tout ça ce
sont des signes positifs et qui nous
permettent de tenir mieux les robinets
de l'économie française poursuit de leur
univers question on attend des mesures
ou tout au moins les entreprises comme
un certain nombre de mesures en leur
faveur et connaîtront quand ces mesures
et bien que je les exposerai en
compagnie de
monsieur dreyfus dans une étroite
collaboration pour une fois ça changera
du passé entre le ministère de
l'industrie le ministère l'économie et
des finances nous exposerons l'ensemble
des dispositifs que nous mettons à la en
faveur des entreprises pour leur
permettre d'investir de renforcer leurs
fonds propres de passer une mauvaise
période mais ça c'est déjà commencé et
de recruter et d'engager la bataille
avec nous contre le chô meurs l'impôt
sur l'eau tu travailles bien l'impôt sur
l'outil de travail il sera aménagé en
fonction de l'ensemble de cette
politique économique
il faut que les règles du jeu soient
claires et bien définies elles le seront
cette semaine une fois pour toutes
je crois qu'après ça en fonction je
voulais dire de cette demande qui
reprend un peu irrégulièrement mais qui
est là je crois que chacun pourra se
mettre au travail le cycle politique
sera derrière nous il est temps que nous
parce pension choses sérieuses c'est à
dire à notre économie à faire
fonctionner nos entreprises à donner à
nos jeunes une chance dans la vie
professionnelle à penser aux immenses
défis qui nous attendent dans les années
80 la france l'a montré même dans cette
période de turbulences politiques je
vous ai indiqué que quelques chiffres
elle en a les moyens pourquoi ne pas
être confiant
et pourquoi ne pas sortir de ce climat
d'incertitude qui je crois a trop pesé
et a trop duré
monsieur de leur merci l'ancien
président de la république monsieur
valéry giscard d'estaing est rentré ce
matin à paris monsieur giscard d'estaing
venait de passer 48 heures aux états
unis à l'invitation de l'ancien
président gerald ford qui ne duraient
une bibliothèque à grande rapide ce
monsieur ronald reagan
il est également présent depuis le mois
de mai depuis sa défaite aux élections
présidentielles monsieur valéry giscard
d'estaing s'est muré dans le silence
certes quelques photos de lui ont été
publiés mais il n'a accordé aucune
interview et n'a publié aucun article
dans la presse écrite
aujourd'hui pour la première fois
l'ancien chef de l'état sort de ce
silence à grand rapids
il a accepté de répondre aux questions
de l'envoyé spécial d'antenne de patrick
clément
au bord de la rivière au centre de grand
rapids le musée gerald ford policiers
sur le qui-vive mesures de sécurité
impressionnantes pour nous mais normal
pour les américains leur président est
présent ils sont plusieurs centaines un
fils à l'oreille reliés à la radio
lunettes noires sur le nez
ils font partie le secret de service et
dominant le tout jumelles en batterie
d'une fois l'édifice
ils sont là pour protéger la tribune la
tribune où ford pour ce qu'on pourrait
appeler son jubilé a invité le président
reagan mais aussi trudeau lopez portillo
et giscard d'estaing tous feront un
discours giscard affirmera sans citer
françois mitterrand qu'il est certain
que la bonne entente entre les deux pays
ne pourra que continuer et puis à la fin
des cérémonies avant de regagner la
france
de retour dans sa chambre d'hôtel l'ex
président de la république nous a
expliqué les raisons et la signification
de sa présence à cette manifestation
vous souvenez sans doute que le
président ford a été président des états
unis lorsque j'étais président de la
république française il était président
depuis le départ du président nixon se
dire le l'été 1974 jusqu'à l'élection de
1976 est donc toute sa présidence s'est
déroulé pendant tu étais moi-même
président de la république française
c'est éventuellement l'occasion de
montrer que la france était ici à côté
des différents pays du continent de
l'amérique du nord il c'était pour moi
l'occasion de rencontrer les dirigeants
notamment le président régal vrai de la
france monsieur le président alors est
ce qu'on te considérais que d'ici deux
grands rapide ou faites votre rentrée
non tout simplement je répond à une
invitation en pensant que le fait de
répondre à cette invitation a permis à
la france d'être présente à cette
manifestation qui était à la fois
populaire et l'amicale g président vous
venez de me dire que magna j'étais
n'était pas politique mais lorsqu'on
voit reggane portillo trudeau sur la
même estrade que vous un peu rencontre
peut considérer que steria jeu politique
mais c'est très simple j'ai répondu à
une invitation je viens de vous le dire
et je n'ai rien de plus à ajouter pour
sa première déclaration depuis le 10 mai
il y a dans les propos de valéry giscard
d'estaing double langage
puisqu'il dit effectuer d'un côté une
vie privée et de l'autre représenter la
france
à l'évidence les deux affirmations ne
sont pas vraiment compatible entre
parenthèses deux hommes politiques
français ont aujourd'hui évoquer
l'avenir de l'opposition il s'agit de
monsieur chaban delmas et de monsieur
jacques blanc s'ils ont lancé un appel
aux recours a dit monsieur chaban-delmas
des querelles de personnes apparaîtrait
est immédiatement quant à monsieur
jacques blanc le secrétaire général du
parti républicain il estime que les
prochaines échéances nationales sont
lointaines et que l'heure n'est donc pas
lui non plus recours après cette
cérémonie et cette interview accordée
donc à notre envoyé spécial monsieur
giscard d'estaing est reparti vers la
france monsieur ronald reagan lui à
retrouver washington et la maison
blanche une maison blanche où il est
difficile de s'entendre en ce moment à
l'appel de la confédération syndicale
afl cio
des dizaines de milliers d'américains
manifestent contre la politique
économique et surtout contre la
politique sociale du président américain
de données par la presse afin qu'en
s'organisant sion de petits travailleurs
rassemblés aujourd'hui autour de la
maison blanche ils sont là devant le
bureau ovale donald ray gun pour
protester contre les coupes dans le
budget s'entraîner à court terme
ces réductions d'emploi fédéraux et les
salaires bloqués pour les fonctionnaires
les manifestants par la voix de leurs
représentants qui ce matin ont comme
slogan reggane ce que ces polonais c'est
bien il ferait mieux de s'occuper de
nous d'abord le temps la manifestation
n'est pas de la violence pour l'instant
sa maison blanche n'exclut rien s'est il
déclaré deux cent mille personnes
fr aujourd'hui dès demain la une des
chaînes de télévision et les journaux
america's objective et assas ils ont
déjà réussi pour cette première
manifestation c'est reagan depuis que ce
dernier était président des états unis
oui c'est bien la première fois qu'une
opposition assure ray gun se manifeste
de façon massive et structuré pour lui
l'état de grâce aura duré beaucoup plus
que 100 jours jusqu'au milieu de l'été
soit plus de six bons mois pendant
lesquels tout lui a réussi y compris la
mise en place d'une politique économique
allant à l'encontre de ce qui se fait
depuis 40 ans il a pu réduire
massivement les impôts et réduire
massivement les dépenses sociales
dans la foulée il a résolu sans dommages
apparents et par la manière forte la
grève des contrôleurs aériens en
licenciant purement et simplement les
grévistes
les premières difficultés sont venus
lorsqu'il a voulu aussi augmenter
massivement les crédits militaires ses
conseillers budgétaire lui ont fait
remarquer à son grand chagrin que
c'était ou contradictoires ou
inflationnistes
aujourd'hui la manifestation washington
est un avertissement sérieux d'autant
plus sérieux que la classe ouvrière
américaine n'est pas par principe
antigone bien au contraire les ouvriers
les professionnels américains ne
s'identifient pas du tout avec la gauche
politique j'ai presque envie de dire
encore bien au contraire
comme si ces contrariétés ne suffisait
pas on dit monsieur le guen ne se porte
pas très bien ces jours ci s large à 70
ans ou les suites de l'attentât dont il
a été victime au printemps aujourd'hui
et demain le président reagan se repose
en principe à camp david et est à
craindre qu'il ne soit pas en train de
passer un très bon week end à l'étranger
encore arrestation à montréal du
physicien italien francesco piperno l'ex
dirigeant du mouvement autonomie
ouvrière qui est accusé par les
autorités italiennes de terrorisme a été
appréhendé à la demande de ses autorités
italiennes rome voudra vient d'obtenir
son extradition
l'union soviétique a reconnu aujourd'hui
avoir perdu des hommes en angola
un soldat est actuellement prisonniers
des troupes sud-africaine moscou demande
que ce spécialiste militaire
les chouettes immédiatement rendus
l'agent staff reconnaît également que 4
soviétique deux hommes et deux femmes
ont été tués lors de l'offensive des
troupes sud africaine en angola encore
des incidents cette nuit dans la
banlieue lyonnaise deux voitures ont été
incendiées à villeurbanne pour le maire
de la ville monsieur charles hernu qui
est aussi le ministre de la défense
les auteurs de ces incidents ne sont
guère plus d'une quarantaine pour
monsieur hernu ces troubles ne justifie
pas la création de comités de défense
lesquels selon lui se dissimule bien mal
d'ailleurs des intentions politiques
une série de non lieu motivés par la loi
d'amnistié votée par le parlement au
début de l'été d'abord non lieu dans la
sphère de la publication par le canard
enchaîné des feuilles d'impôts de
messieurs giscard d'estaing et marcel
dassault fin des poursuites également
dans la sphère des deux radios riposte
monsieur françois mitterrand dont un
message avait été diffusée bien avant
les élections par cette radio
socialistes avaient été inculpées ces
deux dossiers sont aujourd'hui fermé le
dossier des radios libres en revanche
est loin d'être clos à deux reprises
cette semaine le sénat a pris des
positions qui vont à l'encontre des
souhaits du gouvernement
d'abord les sénateurs se sont déclarés
favorables à des radios municipal
ensuite ils ont admis le principe de la
publicité alors il faut d'ailleurs dire
qu'elle certaines radios libres n'avait
pas attendu le feu vert des sénateurs
pour faire de la pub sur leurs antennes
planche à voile venant directement de
versailles sport et si vous voulez
l'adresse slam à 6 personnes et sport 31
et par l'une de ces annonces
publicitaires pour les commerçants
locaux que rfm bien entrée dans le monde
de la radio commerciale pour la plus
importante radio libre elle revendique
deux millions d'auditeurs
le recours à la publicité par est en
effet indispensable accès à la publicité
qu'elle pourrait être le moyen
d'existence de telle radio ce ne
pourrait être que le financement
politique ou le financement de diverses
associations dont les buts ne sont pas
toujours clairement définis et je crois
que s'ils n'y avaient pas accès à la
publicité pour une radio comme rfm et
bien je crois que ce serait ni plus ni
moins que la mort de ce type de station
pas plus de cinq minutes de publicité
par heure pour un tarif de 1000 francs
la minute
tel est le choix de cette radio pour
rémunérer la vingtaine de personnes qui
assurent son fonctionnement 24 heures
sur 24
350 personnes sont portées disparues à
la suite d'un naufrage d'un bateau sur
le fleuve amazone
le bateau transportait d'à peu près 500
passagers il a coulé sur le titre est
rapidement et seuls 150 personnes ont pu
être sauvées les opérations pour essayer
de retrouver d'autres rescapés se
poursuivre aux états unis harris beurre
les voisins de la centrale nucléaire de
three mile island vont être dédommagé 25
millions de dollars ont été débloqués
pour cela une partie de cette somme sera
d'ailleurs consacrée aux recherche
contre le cancer
mais aar iceberg l'inquiétude est revenu
aujourd'hui un nouvel accident ou plutôt
un incident a provoqué une alerte de 4
heures dans le système de
refroidissement du réacteur une fuite
avait été découverte a été colmatée et
aucune radioactivité n'a été décelée
chacun sexy dans une centrale nucléaire
les accidents graves sont improbables
ils peuvent toutefois se produire alors
au centre de formation de la centrale
nucléaire de bugey près de lyon on
s'exerce à tout prévoir
jour après jour
les lumières de la salle de commande
s'éteignent dans la seconde qui suit des
dizaines d'arbres rouge s'allume
c'est l'accident le réacteur c'est chaud
si le responsable ne réagit pas
immédiatement
les barres d'uranium vont fondre
détruisant le coeur de la centrale
nucléaire devant vos yeux se reproduit
seconde par seconde
l'accident de harrisburg du 28 mars 79
aux états unis pourtant cette fois il
s'agit d'un exercice de l'autre côté du
mur un puissant ordinateur simule tous
les accidents imaginables ou déjà arrivé
dans la réalité
on va envoyer quelqu'un en local us que
les pannes techniques ce sont les
défaillances de l'homme que l'on craint
le plus elles sont totalement imprécises
y en deux depuis la salle de commande il
faut qu'à partir des informations que
les gens ont à leur disposition ils se
fassent une idée la plus exacte possible
de ce qui est en train de se passer sur
la machine ça ça suppose d'entraînement
de très longue durée à la fois sur les
simulateurs mais également sur le tas et
sur le matériel il faut que les gens
connaissent parfaitement leur matériel
avant de passer du matériel à la salle
de commande
il faut connaître tout pour pouvoir
piloter de fait c'est uniquement parce
que le pilote de three mile island aux
états unis n'a pas compris ce qui se
passait que la catastrophe est arrivée
en france depuis cet accident le
programme de formation a été intensifiée
mais l'accident reste t'il possible on
peut pas écarter l'hypothèse d'un
accident
disons de même nature que celui d'harry
ce beurre dans une centrale française
cependant je crois que l'on met tout en
oeuvre pour que les gens qui sont en
salle de commande arrive à comprendre ce
qui est en train de se passer et arrive
surtout assurer l'essentiel des
fonctions de sûreté que l'on doit
assurer dans une centrale
mais on peut pas écarter l'hypothèse
qu'un accident pareil se produisait pas
d'avis
oui le tout est de savoir quand un
accident comme celui-là peut se produire
c'est l'une des questions auxquelles
nous essaierons de répondre lundi à
20h30 dans notre magazine affaires vous
concernant pour la troisième année
consécutive la ville de lyon vite à
leurs deux périodes une semaine de
festival pour faire découvrir ou
redécouvrir au public français l'oeuvre
d'un compositeur que nos voisins
d'outre-manche et que les mélomanes
d'outre-atlantique apprécié depuis
extrêmement longtemps festival berlioz
c'est aussi l'occasion pour la
population lyonnaise de participer un
moment d'animation culturelle tout à
fait exemplaire
un reportage de georges beccu et jean
louis ousset berlioz musicien populaire
anp faudrait-il quelques preuves
supplémentaires
les lyonnais sont là spectateurs mais
aussi acteurs les musiciens sont ceux du
conservatoire local et les trente sept
chorales rassemblés sont de la région
la municipalité de lyon et le chef
d'orchestre serge baudo ont gagné leur
pari animé une grande fête et
réhabiliter un compositeur de génie mais
on est bien obligé d'aimer vers l'eau
surtout quand on aime un peu la musique
ça nous attire un petit peu c'est un
petit peu le wagner ya le razer de
français quand on fait le regroupement
et le regroupement total on a déjà bien
travaillé séparément
on sait jouer incertaine corel com ou
s'est joint la pourra les oignons et on
le faisait des répétitions avec la
chorale de riom et ensuite tous les
moyens y avait avec bernard tétu la
réunion de tous les corps et les
chorales grille et donc les gens qui
participent au corps quel type de
profession gilles tous les milieux ah
oui tout à fait
d'où viens-tu le garage est en jeu
antoine dans la loi et tu as préparé ce
concert avec la chorale depuis combien
de temps
les chorales sont la constante du
festival on les retrouve à l'intérieur
de l'auditorium autour de gabriel
bacquier dans béatrice et bénédict un
opéra berlioz injustement ennuyé
le festival c'est aussi la sphère des
grands industriels de la région qui
apportent leur aide financière et celle
des petits commerçants qui manifestent
leur soutien en décorant leur devanture
un thème de vitrines et nous sommes
heureux de nous associer à ce festival
si mon dieu de plus en plus d'ampleur et
il sera de plus en plus connu et vous
même vous allez au concert vous avez la
musique de mes périodes de supprimer
lendemain augmenter parce que mes
loisirs
les remèdes peu dans fire aux basses
étaient très satisfaits d'aller à
l'inauguration
j'ai trouvé ça fantastique fantastic
également la cantatrice jessye norman
dans la mort de cléopâtre
un des temps forts du festival 81
à la côte-saint-andré le village natal
de berlioz à quelques kilomètres de lyon
le festival continue
ici pires réac joue un extrait de la
symphonie fantastique dans les premières
mesures ont été composés dans cette
maison là le jeune hector n'avait alors
que douze ans il était fils de médecin
et lui bien du mal à convaincre sa
famille bourgeoise de sa vocation
musicale
il est vraisemblable que le berlioz
célèbre mais décriée mal jugé par la
critique pour abus de tonitruance et
d'innovation serais heureux d'entendre
cent quarante-quatre ans après sa
création
l'interprétation de son superbe au
requiem dans les conditions qu'il
souhaitait ans en exécutant réunis dans
le palais des sports devant 10000
spectateurs
un événement que le public lyonnais
n'oubliera pas
en sport les springboks sont joué leur
premier match aux états unis un match
dans une quasi clandestinité
une centaine de spectateurs seulement
avaient fait le déplacement
pendant que des manifestants défilaient
régulièrement dans les rues de chicago
pour protester contre la venue des
rugbymen sud-africains aux états unis
cette tournée pourrait d'ailleurs bien
empoisonné le monde du sport
c'est ainsi que l'organisation de
l'unité africaine a fait aujourd'hui au
boycott de toutes les compétitions
auxquelles participent les états unis et
puis je vous rappelle que l'urss a aussi
menacé de boycotter les jeux olympiques
de los angeles en 1984 en france
toujours en sport l'événement du jour
c'est le bol d'or moto qui se court sur
le circuit du castellet devant des
dizaines de milliers de spectateurs sur
le plan des machines la lutte est
purement japonaise les français raymond
roche et jean lafon qui avait fait le
meilleur temps aux essais sur leur
kawasaki cuisine ont d'ailleurs pris un
excellent départ en fait dès le premier
tour
raymond roesch occupaient toujours le
poste de leader après trois heures de
course l'an passé c'est une suzuki qui
avait gagné
voici quelques-uns des meilleurs pilotes
de moto qui participent au bol d'or la
plus célèbre et la plus ancienne épreuve
d'endurance au monde
aucun d'eux ne pense semble que dans les
derniers mois le monde de la moto a vu
disparaître ses plus prestigieuses tête
d'affiche bon chevalier léon rougerie
une véritable hécatombe qui fait se
poser au public et aux médias
l'éternel problème de la sécurité sur
deux groupes en réalité un risque que
les pilotes même acceptant
professionnelle parce que c'est leur
métier
c'est un sport dangereux au même titre
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses dangereuses
par exemple lorsque l'on fait de la moto
sur la route
à mon avis c'est plus dangereux encore
en course car il ya beaucoup plus
d'obstacle éventuels qui peuvent être
nuisibles à la sécurité
eh bien on a vu plusieurs pilotes
français et non des moindres mourir ces
derniers mois alors comment expliquer ce
phénomène bien aimé un français qui
situe effectivement les remarques cadré
mais n'y a cependant pas
mais ce n'est pas parce que on pilote
français se tue en faisant son flow
qu'on parlera autant d'un maçon qui sont
aux commandes d'un échafaudage
et il est vrai que les pilotes sont des
pros dans le comportement sinon dans
l'argent
je prends ma moto je fais mon boulot je
le fais par passion et non pas pour de
l'argent car j'estime que ce que l'on
fait par passion est bien souvent mieux
fait que ce cadeau fait par intérêt la
moto c'est donc une passion qui coûte
cher
la plupart des motards possèdent des
engins de rêve alors que leur salaire
atteint tout juste le smic
que ce soit les pilotes de compétition
où les spectateurs de ce bol d'or
mais il coûte cher aussi en vies
humaines on l'a vu sur les circuits mais
c'est encore plus vrai sur la route où
les deux roues sont les plus exposés
beaucoup de pilotes professionnels
avouent d'ailleurs qu'ils ne veulent pas
conduire sur route parce que c'est trop
dangereux
et pour eux qui prennent des risques
inouïs sur les circuits cet aveu prend
valeur de symbole quand on sait qu'ils
vont courir devant cent mille motards
venus jusqu'à eux justement par la route
et pour ces motards là non plus le
risque il n'y pense pas parce que c'est
toute leur vie et la mort fait un peu
partie du jeu
me dans les pansements un pas du tout ça
sans penser attendant moto ou quelque
chose pour elle va carrément le vélo ça
permet de prendre photos oui et moteurs
qui sont descendus au castellet suivre
le bol d'or qui va rouler toute la nuit
n'ont pas payer l'autoroute ils
reviendront également gratuitement c'est
ce qu'a annoncé un communiqué du
ministère des transports on leur
conseille cependant de respecter les
limitations de vitesse à partir du 3
octobre il n'y aura plus de tirs c'est
le jeudi nature fist seront conviés à
exercer leurs talents sur un art qui
rapporte plus mais qui est aussi plus
difficile puisqu'il s'agira chaque jeudi
d'un kart est alors le quarté c'est plus
dur que le tiercé plus dur en tous les
cas que celui de demain à longchamp va
quand même 23 partants 1 pirotte oui
mais détrompez vous c'est une course
très difficile à déchiffrer ce prix de
belgique il sera le tiercé de deux mâles
en chant il s'agit d'une épreuve
handicap longue de 1200 mètres qui
s'adresse exclusivement pouliches et
comme vous l'avez dit ils sont 23 32
départs sur cette distance et
demoiselles devront faire preuve à la
fois de tenue et de vitesse avec une
aptitude au terrain souple alors j'ai
choisi de faire confiance à presser ce
pirate qui va effectuer une très bonne
course de rentrée julio pause mairie ce
qui reste sur sa forme de deauville made
and bluff en progrès constant sat il a
ensuite malgré son poids élevé 59 kilos
et demi
et puis mauritanie sur les conseils de
bernard sécly son entraîneur lamarre
gallèse frenchy danseurs et ribalta
peuvent également tirer leur épingle du
jeu
alors notez bien leur numéro 16 12 5 1
17 6 10 et 8
merci pirette terminons avec la météo
est avec un avertissement important
laurent bouvier la tempête va souffler
cette nuit sur les côtes françaises fois
que les plaisanciers vont devoir se
méfier non oui une nuit très difficile
pour les gens qui sont en mer il pleut
déjà sur les régions de l'ouest et les
vents se sont considérablement
renforcées ces vents pourraient
atteindre 100 km/heure 100 km heure près
des côtes de la manche mais revenons à
cet après midi avec les températures
relevées à 14h par la météo nationale
des températures en très légère hausse
par rapport à hier de 18 degrés à lille
jusqu'à 25 degrés à ajaccio le temps
pour demain dimanche
eh bien il sera encore doux et
ensoleillé sur le bassin méditerranéen
et encore ce qui va avantager les
pilotes du bol d'or
mais surtout le reste du pays sur
vraiment tout le reste du pays c'est le
temps très très nuageux sur la moitié
nord ils peuvent il pleuvra presque sans
arrêt sur la moitié sud
les pluies seront un peu plus
intermittent seul peut-être il y aura
quelques éclaircies tout à fait dans le
nord de la france dans la soirée les
vents vont faiblir très légèrement mais
ils resteront très fort les températures
pour demain et bien ça ne vous étonnera
pas si je vous dis qu'elles sont en
légère baisse c'est normal avec le temps
qui fait mais elle reste tout à fait
comparable aux normales saisonnières
et pendant que vous regardez notre
agenda un mot du temps pour lundi les
nuages vont continuer mais ils seront un
peu moins abondants les pluies seront
également un peu moins abondantes et le
soleil fera une timide apparition dans
la soirée sur les régions de l'ouest
voilà cette édition est maintenant
terminé demain à 12h45 c'est le
trompettiste maurice andré qui sera
l'invitée d'antenne 2010 notre dernier
journal aujourd'hui vous sera présenté
vers 23h40 42 parce que nous avons un
petit peu débordé par hervé claude
bonsoir madame amélie